allez comme tous les mercredis c'est la
culture la culture c'est de bici
rebonsoir rebonsoir on va parler de 7e
art oui on parle de 7e art parce que
événement phare pour la ville de Bois
d'Arcy le festival mémoire destoiles de
l'écrit à l'écran revient donc cette
année pour une 12e édition alors pour en
parler ce soir nous recevons claire
Duval vous êtes directrice de l'action
culturelle et Philippe Lejeune bonsoir
vous êtes adjoint au maire en charge de
la cultur donc pour la ville de bois
d'Arc tous les deux donc le festival
démarre le 28 juin quel est le peut-être
clair je m'adresse à vous en premier
quel est le principe de ce festival
alors le principe mémoire d'étoile c'est
un festival qui existe depuis 12 ans et
le sous-titre du festival c'est mémoire
d'étoile de l'écrit à l'écran donc jeens
à préciser juste que mémoire d'étoile
c'est pas étoile qui brille dans le ciel
c'est toile comme une toile c'est voilà
ça évidemment il y a le il y a le jeu de
mot aussi mais voilà ça ça joue
précisément làdessus la
magie explicité c'est pas cassé mais euh
donc de l'écrit à l'écran puisque le
principe c'est de revisiter un certain
nombre de films majeurs euh voilà toutes
toutes époques confondues avec un lien
particulier par rapport au patrimoine
puisque sur la ville de boisarsie nous
avons les Archives françaises du film
donc c'était
aussi et puis voilà leur rendre hommage
et de proposer des films dans lesquels
l'écrit de manière générale joue un rôle
important alors qu'il s'agisse
d'adaptation strict ou alors de de film
où il y a un lien particulier voilà
montré avec l'écrit donc ça c'est le
concept général et là-dessus se greffe
ch chaque année une thématique
particulière donc cette année a été
retenue la thématique de la justice
voilà bah alors pourquoi Philippe leum
pourquoi la justice pourquoi ce choix
parce y a une prison àarc ah non marquz
ça aurait pu effectivement ben en fait
vous savez on c'est pendant un festival
finalement qu'on choisit le thème du
festival suivant h HM et euh donc
l'année dernière l'année dernière on
voilà c'est c'est clair d'ailleurs qui
avait proposé la justice l'année d'avant
pour les les arts et la création c'était
moi en fait comme on est tous les deux
très cinéphiles et qu'on a en tête un
certain nombre de titres
finalement pendant le festival les idées
viennent et voilà une idée germe donc là
cette année ça a été la justice parce
que c'est l'idée qui est venue tout
simplement parce que vous saviez vous
aviez déjà en tête quelques films qui
pourraiit tout à fait correspondre à
coui instantané c'est dire que c'est la
justice mais c'est la justice dans un
sens quand même assez assez large he voà
voilà c'est pas uniquement la justice il
y a quelques quelques films prtoi par
exemple il y a des films qui sont je
prends l'exemple de ressources humaines
de Laurent Kanté qui est davantage un
film sur on va dire la justice ou
l'injustice sociale vous avez des films
comme fure de fritzlang où là c'est
plutôt la justice de la foule qui se
fait donc justice elle-même donc c'est
pas c'est pas uniquement la justice al
il y a quelques films de prêtoir comme
je disais mais c'est la justice au sens
plus large Chicken Run par exemple pour
les enfants film d'animation Raz pas le
rapport non la la révolte et la
rébellion parfois voilà c'est pour
combattre l'injustice or Ginger et ses
petites copines pou voilà se Rebell
contre
l'oppression ambiante mais Chicken Run
c'est aussi parce que on cherche à
toucher tous les publics aussi bien les
jeunes que les moins jeunes avec des
films de tout genre et y compris des
films d'animation et comme Chicken Run
est un excellent film c'était ça aurait
été dommage de pas le diffuser de le
redécouvrir sur grand écran parce que
l'intérêt aussi même si ce sont des
films qui sont certains très connus les
voir au cinéma c'est c'est pas du tout
la même chose que de les voir chez soi
même si on a un équipement exceptionnel
le cinéma c'est quand même un grand
écran c'est aussi un public c'est
partager des émotions justement bah dans
la salle obscure quoi c'est c'est
l'intérêt du cinéma alors leader tenu
c'est vraiment la la notion de diversité
c'est ça donc mélange des genres euh des
époques des pays aussi parce que vous
allez présenter quelques projections
étrangères notamment mal je crois alors
il y a un film malien effectivement BAMO
de d'abderahman sisako qui est un film
splendide un film japonais avec
barberous de Kurosawa un film israélien
avec les citronniers de heran riclis un
film argentin avec dans ses yeux de Ran
rossé Canella enfin voilà on essaie de
de d'aller à la fois loin dans le dans
le temps puisque voilà on remonte cette
année à 1899 quand même avec un cour
métrage de mélias sur l'affaire defus et
puis aller loin aussi dans l'espace et
en proposant toujours les films en VO
soustittré voilà pour que même si on ne
comprend pas la langue on s'imprègne h
alors la programmation donc comme comme
on l'a entendu là est vraiment
éclectique est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner quelques temps fort de ces 15 15
jours de festival ah ben c'est-à-dire
que il y a toujours des des moments de
rencontre par
exemple il y a bon des réalisateurs il y
a Claude Jean-Philippe qui qui vient
depuis c'est la 11e année un habitué
ouais c'est un fidèleement enfin c'est
quand même un fidèle on va dire de de
grand talents puisque il a tout de même
présenté enfin c'est une encyclopédie du
cinéma cet homme c'est assez
extraordinaire et donc pour pour
rappeler celui qui présentait le
cinéclub sur France 2 donc du temps où
où il y avait un cinéclub je crois qu'il
n'existe plus mais il y a donc des
rencontres avec des écrivains mais aussi
des rencontres avec des critiques il y a
des rencontres euh bah avec les archives
du film puisque chaque année on leur
propose une carte blanche donc cette
année c'est l'affaire drefus CLA le
disait voilà c'est je pour les jeunes
public oui et le soir donc le fadrefus
avec notamment le court-métrage de de
mliè euh il y a aussi une soirée qui est
organisée par le Conseil Municipal des
jeune ils ont même préparé un quiz donc
donc il y a différents des rencontres
des animations et parmi les animations
j'ai noté donc la la visite des Archives
françaises du cinéma parce que vous
souhaitez vraiment leur leur rendre
hommage et c'est un vrai partenaire sur
ce projet c'est ça qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire oui ben au départ si
vous voulez on est quand on a lancé le
festival on s'était d'abord assuré que
les archives
était à nos côtés donc on a eu tout de
suite une réponse très positive de leur
part et ils non ils ont toujours été
présents donc c'est l'occasion donc
chaque année de visiter leur leur site
ce qui je le rappelle n'est pas n'est
pas comment dire une une tradition quoi
ils n'ont pas vocation ils ont vocation
à archiver les films à les restaurer pas
à faire visiter donc là ils ouvrent
leurs portes exceptionnellement pour les
euh dans le cadre du festival ils le
font chaque année donc c'est le
mercredi juillet al on on a vu aussi à
l'écran quelques images d'une exposition
qui a lieu en parallèle une exposition
autour du du matériel cinématographique
de de des techniques d'imag euh là aussi
comment s'est passé le le partenariat
avec c'est une association hein c'est ça
qui alors là oui on a travailler avec le
cinéma s'expose donc ce sont deux frères
les frères loubau qui sont des
passionnés de cinéma et qui ont collecté
depuis des années tout un tas de
matériel qui ont trait voilà à
l'histoire des techniques du cinéma donc
l'exposition porte précisément sur sur C
cette thématique et c'est une exposition
alors vous verrez c'est dans dans la
salle des fêtes sur le site de la ferme
de la tremblée donc 400 m² avec tout un
tas de matériel vraiment émouvant vous
avez la caméra qui a servi à filmer les
tontons flingueurs enfin voilà c'est
c'est bon évidemment tout ça légendé
avec et avec tout un parcours et c'est
une exposition aussi qui est
rendue possible grâce grâce au soutien
de la Communauté d'Agglomération de
Versailles Grand Parc puisque la
communauté d'agloot depuis l'année
dernière a choisi de sou de soutenir sur
le le territoire intercommunal trois
événements le moisolière à Versailles le
festival de la BD à Buc et le festival
mémoire d'étoil de boisarcie donc
l'année dernière on avait accueilli un
spectacle orienté théâtre de rue une
cerise noire et cette année donc cette
cette très très belle exposition qui
aura ensuite vocation pour tout tout
parti à être proposé sur d'autres
communes de du territoire d'accord alors
donc on rappelle les les dates donc ça
démarre le 28 juin jusqu'au 12 juillet
donc le festival est
majoritairement donc à la Grange de la
tremblae sauf quelques séances qui sont
déportées à savoir à Fontenel fleurie et
saint-cir qui qui travaille aussi du
coup les cinémas travaillent en
partenariat sur sur ce projet et juste
pour une petite information donc du coup
cette année le festival marque aussi
l'instauration d'une activité régulière
cinéma pour la grange de la tremblae qui
a été cette salle a été réhabilité pour
le cinéma je crois alorsit la salle a
été construite pour faire un lieu de
spectacle donc qu'on a déjà mis en route
la la partie spectacle vivant et donc
dès le départ on avait évidemment
l'intention d'en faire aussi un cinéma
et donc là on a fait quelques séances
d'essaiis en mars et avril dè septembre
et donc en septembre on démarre
effectivement avec une programmation
régulière donc ça fera une offre de
cinéma en plus plusur plus mais le alors
je tiens à préciser que le festival on
l'a pas dit c'est entièrement qui dure
15 jours là c'est entièrement gratuit
tout est gratuit en fait c'est
entièement gratuit donc on peut venir
sans aucun problème à partir de
septembre là ce sera un cinéma payant
évidemment alors toutes les infos sont
se enfin il faut se reporter évidemment
au site euh pour toute la programmation
on laisse les les téléspectateurs euh
s'y retrouver de de cette manière en
tout cas merci beaucoup merci de votre
participation